el texto más vendido por estos días en
chile
[Música]
los vendedores ambulantes venden decenas
de ejemplares a diario como cuánto se
vende en guardia
el libro que contiene 388 artículos e
incluye temas sobre los derechos
sociales el género la política y el
medio ambiente atiza la polarización que
vive el país sudamericano y ha
despertado gran interés entre los
ciudadanos no toda la gente se vale
es súper bien
hay gente de buena fe
en el tema
[Aplausos]
esta nueva constitución cuyo texto será
refrendado en un plebiscito el 4 de
septiembre reemplazaría a la actual que
data de la dictadura de augusto pinochet
y que causas rencillas entre la
población por consagrar un modelo
económico neoliberal
orientado al mercado que llevó a chile a
un crecimiento económico durante décadas
pero que dejó de lado las políticas
sociales ocho de cada diez chilenos
votaron a favor de redactar una nueva
constitución hace dos años tras las
fuertes protestas sociales que
sacudieron al país pero el apoyo ha
caído en los últimos meses debido a
algunas propuestas consideradas
radicales ya las controversias que
rodean a la asamblea encargada de
redactar el texto